if you're a parent of a child under the
age of 12 let me ask you a question when
is the last time or even the first time
you let them walk to school by
themselves have an unscheduled playdate
or god forbid let them go to the store
to pick up a gallon of milk by
themselves kids today are tagged
surveilled and tracked like endangered
species is it any wonder that our
college campuses now rushed to provide
safe spaces and panic rooms to protect
young adults from speakers of material
which they might find disturbing kids
are supervised all the time and to
discuss the challenges in American
childhood and what to do about them i
sat down with Lenore skinny's the author
of free-range kids and a regular
contributor to Reason scan a Z is
launching a new nonprofit called let
grow along with psychology professors
Jonathan Hite and Peter gray and Daniel
shuckman who's the chairman of the
foundation for individual rights and
education the organization will champion
policies research and mindsets promoting
childhood independence autonomy and
resilience skin AZ and height make the
case for let grow in the cover story of
Reason magazines December issue which is
on sale now
what has changed and what what defines
American childhood that kids are
supervised all the time and the idea of
letting a kid out unsupervised has
become so unusual that that's when
people you know when people see a kid
walking outside sometimes they call 911
because they don't know I mean should a
child ever be unsupervised and then the
cops come and they don't know isn't that
dangerous so it's constant supervision
of one sort or another in the story you
you mention an incident where a kid was
outside chopping and the police end up
showing right so kids outside chopping
wood in the suburb of Chicago which is I
grew up in the suburbs of Chicago he was
in his teens and a person walked by saw
the kid thought oh my god a child an axe
anything terrible could happen call 911
the police came why do you have an axe
why are you chopping wood here and he's
like I wanted to build a fort me and my
friends are gonna build a fort well they
confiscated the police confiscated the
axe and he had another tool and they
gave them to his parents for safekeeping
and to me that's the Land of Lincoln
no that's that there there's a history a
blinking would have been picked up on
the 1st of 12 miles he was walking to
school right then putting the pokey
until his parents being right or giving
a little extra homework and some reading
or something that will really develop
him because chopping wood and building
something and doing something with your
friends and having any autonomy all
those are terrible what's really
important is a little more homework
you've been writing about this for years
now calling attention to it yeah and the
story that got you started on this was
when you let one of your kids ride the
subway home in New York yeah which made
you into the world's worst mom all right
first gave me America's worst mom and
then it yeah now you know you're and
you're battling it out to be the world's
worst mom on Mars
tell us about what what was that story
and why was that emblematic really of
what you're talking about with let grow
so I let my nine-year-old ride the
subway alone because he'd been asking if
he could do it and we decided it was
safe and smart and good because he was
familiar with the subways and so are we
we let him go I wrote a column about it
and two days later I was on The Today
Show MSNBC Fox News and NPR and I got
described as America's worst mom I
struggled with why for a long time
because whenever I was in being
interviewed by one of the TV shows or
whatever there'd come a point in the
interview when the the lady or the man
would lean over and say but Lenore how
would you have felt if he never came
home and I never had a good answer oh
you know I have my spare son at home you
know yeah your weekends would suddenly
open up yeah yeah less I don't have to
say for college I mean all sorts I mean
I never knew what to say
there was no good answer to that and I
finally figured out the reason there was
no good answer is because it wasn't a
question how would I felt I think they
knew and so why were they asking because
that was my crime my crime was I didn't
go to how terrible I'd feel if I let him
ride the subway and somebody kidnapped
him and then they raped him and they
killed him and if I you know and how I
found I only I'd been with him it would
have never happened I won't let it
happen that's what you're supposed to do
to be a good parent today is go to the
very darkest place first I call it worst
first thinking think of the worst case
scenario first think about how terrible
you would feel how you could have
prevented it if only you had been there
and therefore not let them do anything
on their own and that's that's what's
describing childhood today never letting
kids do anything on their own because of
the fear that something terrible could
happen or that they will fall behind
because I'm giving them free time but
they could have been in Mandarin so
there's the the fear of children being
raped killed eaten and then there's the
fear of them not getting into Harvard
and hurt their there parallel and yeah
this is all happening against a backdrop
of incredible safety for children as
well so discuss that I mean that the one
of the most bizarre things is that we're
treating our kids more and more as kind
of Faberge eggs
and you know you you just can't let them
out of your sight they have to be in
shrink-wrap all the time of bubble wrap
all the time and at the same time the
social reality is that children have
never been safer I know and sometimes
when I say there's never been a safer
time to be a child people say that's
because we're watching them all the time
it's like but there's also never been a
safer time to be an adult I mean crime
is back to the level it was in 1963 the
the safety might be one of these ironic
things that the safer you get the safer
you think it can be I mean now that
we've almost eliminated all childhood
dangers the fact that anything bad could
ever happen to a kid looms even larger
and to go back to Lincoln why not he had
four children and one of them made it to
adulthood and people didn't say what a
terrible dad oh my god he's just he's
America's worst dad they understood that
children's fate was it was fate right
that there were bigger forces at work
than just whether we were watching over
our kids enough but nowadays we don't
have that because every almost everybody
makes it and so if somebody doesn't make
it or the fear of somebody doesn't make
it means that you must be watching all
the time and then the thing that worries
me is that as much as we're walking with
our kids and staying with our kids and
driving our kids now there's technology
to watch literally every step they take
and did they get on the bus and are they
texting when they got there and who are
they emailing and let me read their text
and you can see so much of your kid's
life that that's going to become the
norm how come you didn't know so you're
supposed to know literally everything
that's going on in your kids life and
you you you open by saying it's like
universal parole it's more like prison
you know everything they do and say and
eat and read is being supervised by
somebody worrying about is this going to
hurt them in the article you mention a
statistic which is stunning that in a
you know in a recent year it's what it's
like a couple of dozen kids have been
kidnapped by strangers yeah I mean it it
always it doesn't mean it's you know
that's their yeah kind of paradigmatic
fear right
it is gonna end up on the milk carton
even though we don't drink out of milk
out of cartons anymore but it's that
type of thing but that's a completely
phantom fear it is a phantom fear but
when you think about when the pictures
appeared on the milk cartons it was in
the mid 80s
and those children are now today's
parents and they grew up you know when
when they put the kids pictures on the
milk cartons it felt like every morning
you were looking at a child who had been
disappeared and nobody ever explained by
the way 90% of those were children taken
in a custody battle or Runaways nobody
explained that and so it felt like
children were being you know as many as
there were milk cartons in the world
those were children that were missing
and I feel like the National Center for
Missing and Exploited Children exploited
us with that fear without ever breaking
it down to the idea that stranger
abductions are extremely rare and the
statistic I give in my book is if you
wanted your kid to be kidnapped by a
stranger how long would you have to keep
them outside unsupervised for that to be
statistically likely to happen it's sort
of like how many lottery tickets would
you have to buy to be statistically
likely to win how many how many how long
you know hundreds of thousands I think
the only one most people say I don't
know three hours there's five minutes
you're out in the parking lots of gogo
bars and things you would have to work
out you would have to work on it because
the guys are going to gogo bars want the
go-go girls and they don't want your
seven-year-old whiner but why do we say
let me tell you the answer it is it's
750,000 years well I'd have to keep them
outside and after the first hundred
thousand years they're not yeah they've
aged down they've aged out yeah they're
not really in the story and let grow you
have Peter Gray who a phenomenal
developmental psychologist who looks at
the role of free play and unstructured
play in mammals including you Jonathan
Hyde who written the author at the
righteous mind really interesting
character particularly in speech battles
and and kind of intellectual diversity
and kitties what is the connection
between the way we treat our kids as
human veal you know as kids and then
when they go to college is there a
connection that you guys are making
there there is a connection
and there's Mike one of my favorite
artifacts from our culture that I talked
about in the recent article is a
question/answer that ran in parents
magazine and the question is your child
is old enough to stay home alone for
short while while you run errands or
whatever and that's no problem but now
she has a playdate coming over
are you allowed to run to the dry
cleaners while the friend is over and
the answer was absolutely not are you
crazy what if there's a squabble you
want to be there to intervene and to me
that's the rosetta stone for the
connection between childhood and what
we're seeing on campus because you've
been told that your child cannot handle
even a spat with a friend without adult
intervention because somebody's feelings
could get hurt and when you're
instructed that way by the bible of
parenting which is Parents magazine that
your kids can't handle it it's too
traumatic your job is to make sure that
nothing ever rises to that level then
you kind of get to campus and nobody
wants to be in an argument or hear
anything that they don't want to hear or
if they are in an argument they need to
run to a safe space or protest the fact
that somebody's saying something that's
going to make them uncomfortable because
we've been taught as parents we're not
helicopter parents by nature we've been
taught that we must not trust our kids
in any kind of human interaction only
adults can handle these things for them
and they get to college and they haven't
had the I mean obviously they've had
some arguments and they've had some free
time but they haven't had huge swathes
of it like we did growing up or like any
generation before us where they had to
argue and get mad and then realize no I
want to keep playing okay and hold it
together and then you start playing
again and things get okay again they
don't know that things get okay again
because they've never gotten to that
point and that seems to be a key to what
you what you guys are talking about is
resilience that idea that you know life
is kind of rough and tumble and you know
and we're not talking about pathological
stuff here I mean we're talking about
just the scrum of everyday life where
you you know you
pest you get angry you get disappointed
the trial yeah and you know that seems
to be what is missing right and we're
designing childhood and young adulthood
with where resilience can't develop
because you're never really confronted
with that type of thing to overcome
right and that's why Peter Graves work
is it so important than why he's part of
this Fab Four team he writes about the
importance of free play and he points
out that when you're in Little League
you got adults telling you when the game
starts when the game ends is the ball in
or out who's playing what position and
when your turn is okay you learn how to
bat I'll grant you that but when kids
are playing a game first of all they
have to figure out what game they're
gonna play and if they make up the rules
they have to explain it to each other
and if you have a bunch of different
ages while the 12 year old is going to
throw it later to the six-year-old
because the six year old you know you
don't want to want them and you'll look
like an idiot so you're learning empathy
and teamwork and that you make the rules
that's democracy I want to change the
rules okay what do you want to do I want
to play it backwards okay
let's decide on that and if and you and
you're hanging out with kids of
different ages as well as opposed to
being stratified constant right
right one of the things Peter gray
points out is that when you're with just
the you know the eight-year-old soccer
team all you can do is compete you know
there's other eight-year-olds who's the
best but when you're the eight-year-old
with the five-year-old like I just saw
my my kids friend just drop and she just
dropped him off on the bus this morning
and there's two seven and
eight-year-olds who tuck in who put the
five-year-old between them and put on
his seat belt and they get to be you
know they're eight but they get to rise
to the occasion that's a little bit of
maturity training and then the
five-year-old doesn't want to keep
crying on the bus because he doesn't
want to look like a baby to the
seven-year-old and we've taken all that
out of their lives and we've given them
structured activities that teach them a
skill but not the skills that come
naturally and play we've given them
something but we've taken away something
that was always there until now which is
learning how to be a human by being
around other humans and playing because
the drive to play makes you get along
and and get frustrated and then get
along again it
reminds me when you were talking about
Little League of in the original Bad
News Bears which came out of in 1976 the
kids at the end there they're coached by
an alcoholic played by Walter Matthau at
the end of the season they lose the big
game spoiler alert but they come close
and they drink beer at the end like they
had instead of champagne but yeah in the
remake that was made a few years ago
with Billy Bob Thornton to coach the
coach is a recovering alcoholic who
drinks near beer and at the end they
break out near beer but they don't even
drink it
this seems to kind of mark different
stages of American childhood how did it
get this way what what are the causes
because it's not the kids the kids
haven't changed its parents have changed
and as you were saying we you know we're
both baby boomers we grew up in an era
where you know I'm thinking of you know
in 1979 I guess I was in high school but
there was a band called The Runaways
with Joan Jett and Lita Ford and you
know there was kind of a celebration of
like kids just being out of control and
I'm watched and crazy not all a good
thing obviously there's problems with
that but you know what happened why are
we and Gen Xers also famously left alone
by their parents their parents were too
busy you know getting divorced or doing
drugs or getting on with life how did
how did we get this way one is the media
the media was not 24/7 when we were
growing up and of course there's nothing
that the media likes more than the story
of a stranger kidnapping a white
middle-class child and those get
repeated through the drama shows the CSI
is the law and orders there was actually
a law and order based on a nine-year-old
wanting to take the subway alone and but
my son I take it he didn't make it okay
well he made it he made it to school I
he didn't make it home anyway there's a
little society that we're floating
around in you start looking like a
lawyer at everything wow I could have
sued for that Wow that's dangerous wow I
can't believe that you know this this
tag this zipper thing fell off that
could be a choking as ice yeah by
my hoodie my kid got strangled for five
seconds with the hoodie on a on a
playground slot right right right and I
can't believe it that's the slide is to
blame the park and Recreation Department
is to blame and the hoodie is to blame
we live in an expert culture experts
like the like that Parents magazine are
always telling you that you're not doing
it right and so they come up with this
new level of perfection and then you
follow it and then that's not good
enough they come up with some new level
of perfection you have to breastfeed for
six months eight months eight years you
know forever and then we live in a
capitalist society which I celebrate but
there's no easier dollar to get from any
human being than the dollar of a parent
was afraid and you could save them so
now there's all the monitors and stuff
that could let you actually put on your
baby your healthy baby home from from
the hospital in the crib you put on this
little sock and it measures their
heartbeat breathing rate temperature
movement and blood oxygen level which
normally I mean hitherto had been
measured only if your child was in
neonatal intensive care but now that's a
level of care that you're supposed to be
you know using with your healthy baby at
home at sleep so if you're not even
allowed to let your kid be asleep at
home and finally you can relax and drink
break out the near beer you know parents
are being driven crazy by this and the
overarching thing and sort of to get
back to your original idea that that
children are under parole is this idea
that we can control everything we
control so many things you can control
the temperature of your house from your
car on your phone and it feels like we
can control literally everything our
children encounter and you start
thinking that you are in complete
control and the idea of not being in
complete control scares you because you
could have you could have been watching
them on a map to see where they were
going and you weren't and how come and
so this level of sort of godlike
omniscience is one that parents are
forced to take on and it's driving them
crazy and it's driving their kids crazy
one of the reasons parents can't let go
is that the old milestones are buried
you know my mom knew when you start
school you sent when kids start school
you walk them to school the first
and then they go right and then you know
at eight or nine you might be a latchkey
kid and that was okay and then at ten
you might have a paper route and at
twelve you'd be a babysitter and
everybody thought that these were normal
acceptable milestones and now no because
they have to go to piano or I have to be
driving them or the school won't let
them be self released until fifth grade
and so these milestones are buried and
so the one way to unbury them is to make
it normal again for parents to let their
kids do something so the first let grow
project is getting schools to have
teachers who say to the kids okay today
when you go home ask your parents if you
can do one thing that you feel you're
ready to do that for one reason another
you haven't done yet you could walk the
dog make dinner if you're in a dangerous
neighborhood you could you know go pick
up your brother from soccer you could
get yourself ready and go to school in
the morning you ride your bike to the
library anything that we would have done
literally without a second thought
and because the school is endorsing it
and because all the other kids are doing
things so you're not the only crazy
parent the parents generally let them do
something and from the limited times
I've done this in some schools to date
the parents are are almost unbelievably
ecstatic at the projects like I'm look
here he comes oh my god she got the milk
oh this is my kid she walked all the way
you're gonna do it tomorrow
parents don't remember literally don't
remember why they were so afraid to let
their kid walk three blocks or wait
alone at the bus stop because now it
seems so obvious and this is this is my
latest revelation if you'll feel barely
worth it it's um I I didn't understand
why the parents would be so ecstatic
about something so minor but what I
finally figured out is that it's
actually deeper than that I think it's
that we all realize that as much as
we're doing for our kids at some point
we will die and our children will be
there without us and finally we have
proof that that's going to be okay so I
feel like it's this profound thing that
just is a school project and it doesn't
take any money it doesn't take any class
time it doesn't take any preparations so
I think that trying to spread the let
grow project in schools which were doing
in seven schools
Long Island now and to here in the city
in New York I think that's gonna I think
people are gonna look at that and go our
school can do that too so there's the
project another one and this is Peter
Gray's baby is after school free play
all right so we were just talking about
all the stuff you get from play you know
you you solve disputes and you deal with
you know being angry and not knowing
what to do and you organize yourselves
and and yet after school like at this
school my kids went to there was
after-school robotics and knitting and
chess and this and that but there was no
chance for free play so just offer that
as an option and half the free play
literally be free play I want somebody
in the corner who's like a lifeguard who
is you know going in if there's you know
actual blood or you know they have the
EpiPen right but otherwise they're not
interfering and we're going to try to
get some schools the first ones that are
doing this anyway
a box of loose parts which is PVC pipe
and fabric and Springs and tape and
boxes and so the thing to riggs catch
your eggs yeah some needles yeah yeah
limited limited and that way they have
to share okay yeah what we're working on
it you got it you got a shotgun right
right got a gimmick anyways the idea is
that kids will have a place where
there's enough like when my kids came
home and I'd wanted them to go outside
there's there weren't other kids outside
so you can't really get a kid to go
outside unless there's another kid
outside so this way you have you know
critical mass of kids there the
different ages like we were talking
about maybe there's a box of junk maybe
there isn't it's obviously a safe enough
space that parents feel okay about
letting them be there and then it also
gives parents something you know a place
to keep them for three to six so it
works for everybody and it's cheap it's
like you have a couple of supervisors
they could be high school kids just
watching so we're trying to get that
underway and then we're trying to get
towns to go become let grow towns where
they announce that look when we see kids
outside we will not arrest the parents
imagine that right so they would pass
the electro Bill of Rights our children
deserves you have the right to some
unsupervised time we have the right to
give it to them without getting arrested
and and you don't get rid of all the
cops or Child Protective Services you
just enlist them in supporting kids
outside as opposed to arresting the
parents who let them play outside and
then we're doing some fun contests that
have not started yet but will be
starting very soon and one of them is
think for yourself and it's an essay
contest trying to get kids to realize
that like like one question is something
like tell us write a thank-you letter to
the jerk who was wrong until you
realized oh they had a point or talk
about a time you had a big fight with a
friend and how you got over it just to
remind them like the Sturm and Drang of
inter personal relationships isn't the
end of the world it's the beginning of
something fine which is you know
exchanging ideas may be taking some in
maybe arguing your point more forcefully
but nobody has to protect you from free
speech and whatever you want to read or
think about or talk about and then
finally we have this one silly contest
because you know I love contests which
is asking kids to come up with the name
of their favorite TV show or book or
movie imagining if their main character
had been overprotected and so it's like
James and the Giant Peach cut into tiny
little pieces so as not to pose a
choking hazard you know that's just to
get younger kids thinking about it like
wait a minute you know Tom Sawyer wasn't
always with his mom how come I don't
have any adventures or freedom so we
just want to start breaking you know
breaking into the children's
consciousness that they deserve the
freedom that their parents had to read
the field talk run and then helping
parents realize that you know this this
fear has been shoved down your throats
it's not natural it's it's put upon us
by the marketplace and the litigious
society the experts or whatever and you
can be ourselves well it becomes
internalized but it's it's a lot of
these outside factors I mean the wanting
your child to be safe and grow up to
outlive you is the natural thing
thinking that you have to stand at the
bus stop with them every day with the
five other parents and the five other
kids until the bus comes is not natural
that's super imposed we've been talking
with Lenore Eskenazi she's the author of
free-range kids she's a contributor to
reason and she along with Jonathan Hite
have the cover story in the December
issue of Reason which announces the let
grow foundation
and an organization devoted to creating
an atmosphere in which children can
become independent and resilient and
move into adulthood in a mature and
productive fashion thanks so much Lenoir
thank you Nick for reason I'm Nikolas
[Music]